the whole thing of course was very
Groundhog Day because we've ended this
show before so I was very conscious this
time of being conscious I was focused on
purpose trying to think done look eight
14 years ago when we finished eight
seasons I probably wasn't as conscious
as they should have been I was probably
ready for the next thing I think we were
all ready to take a little break and and
so you're not fully appreciating what
you may never have again which we
shouldn't have had again it's kind of
bizarre the whole reboot culture and
that we were such a early and big part
of it because when you get a second
chance at anything it's everything is
different everything smells different
and taste different and I and I I
certainly I'm not I'm not guilty of not
appreciating at this time around it's a
gone dead eyed man who never changes and
looks down on everyone it's such a hard
balance particularly in sitcom but in
television in general but the idea of
how do you give the audience what they
want every week which is their
characters their way but also give them
growth and it was hard the first time
around because we we had characters that
were getting to their late 30s and they
still weren't married and they still
didn't have kids and there's a weird
social pressure and at the same time a
pressure not to mess with the show this
time around I think there was a chance
to say okay look they had they both got
married they didn't have kids we got rid
of that but it gave us that story to
tell possibly better I think we told the
story better this time because first of
all is weird that two people their age
we're having kids in two different two
very different ways but also that now
they just as we appreciated the reboot
they really get a chance to appreciate
that they have a shot at at Parenthood
glad you're home how about a crepe thing
I'll see you later Lucy come here the
first time I saw Deborah fully
transformed it was the first time that
Lucy Arnez saw Deborah happened to be in
our hallway where our dressing rooms in
the makeup room are and and I met Lucy
and nice to meet you and I'll she's a
big fan of the show and then suddenly
her mother walks out of a room and and
it was stunning I knew it would be
anyway I mean for 20 years we've known
how how much debt would look like Lucy
and how good she'd be but to see Lucy
see Lucy was crazy I write a check to
the beauty parlor every month yes I know
that but they don't always have a little
note at the back like this one
dear teller be a lamb and don't put
these through till next month
people are gonna put the scenes side by
side or we should and and you know if we
get it right enough let's drag about it
twisted let's but we have to insist on
it and so that's how that was from the
primal one that was the the order of the
day and and everybody eventually
embraced that for sure but I I just
thought I want if anyone ever does see
that scene with the four of us side by
side I want to make sure that every
single thing I'm doing is exactly what
he did
and and that was the fun part of it for
sure and I don't think anyone has taken
there's that scene yet but I dare them
to as I literally do every single thing
he does